[Musique]
dans sa forme la plus simple du passé de
la farine de l'eau de la levure et du
sel
ces ingrédients proportionnée donne un
teint pain avec une me tendre et une
croûte croustillante et bien dorer les
pains tranchés sur les étagères
d'épicerie ne se limite pas à ces seuls
ingrédients au québec
oui le sucre dans notre pain il y en a
des meilleurs cadeaux au canada il
n'existe pas de définition précise de ce
qu'est un pain et des ingrédients qu'il
peut ou doit contenir le sucre entrent
dans la composition des pins blancs et
des paillettes burger dans une
proportion qui varie entre 6 et 12%
mais c'est un ingrédient de base dans la
majorité des pins les seuls patrons pas
de succès la baguette française et par
la suite dépend ce qu'on appelle sans
succès anglo ajouté parce qu'il ya du
sucre naturellement dans la farine
mais par la suite ils ont tous du sucre
à différents niveaux
lorsqu'on n'a pas de sucre ont fait un
peu écouté le sucre amincie la courte
donc pu être plus est chaud puis le
sucre aussi va servir un peu à ça qui va
servir à accélérer la levée de la pâte à
pain blanc est fait en industrie c'est
75% plus courts à faire à fabriquer
qu'un pain artisanal
on n'a pas besoin nécessairement de
sucre sont fait bien lever la patte à la
base le sucre nippone est essentielle à
ce moment-là 25 minutes de cuisson
pour ça suc c'est vraiment parlant
visuellement la le consultant
boulangerie mario fortin connais bien
les effets du sucre lors de la
confection du pain où elle suit la
coloration et pour un pain qui contient
peu ou pas de sucre demeurera plus pâle
malgré une cuisson plus longue est
l'artisan et y ont souvent pas de chef
dans leur pays mais les paies tranchées
qu'on achète dans l'air dans l'industrie
que ce soit 1,6 à 12,1 14h20 céréales et
ont tous dessus
ici j'ai un pays multi grecs à un gramme
par deux tranches et s'y tiennent
multigrains 8,4 g porte deux tranches
dont on voit la différence dessus on
voit la différence de coloration de la
croûte qui est beaucoup plus foncé qu'à
plus de jeu et on voit la différence
aussi dans ce qu'on fait les tous leurs
outils le matin qu'en cas pas dessus ça
finit par regretter ici c'est long parce
que pas dessus alors que le cac on note
succès game beaucoup plus vite au canada
comme en irlande le lait les oeufs et le
pain sont considérés comme essentiels
ils sont exemptés de taxes de vente pour
favoriser leur accessibilité franchisés
de la chaîne de restauration subway en
irlande a demandé sans succès que c'est
pas un sous marin soient eux aussi
exemptés de taxes
la cour suprême a répondu que les bains
en question contenait plus de 2 % de
sucre donc taxable les déclarants même
des produits de confiserie je crois
qu'ils savent pas de quoi ils parlent
quand on met de la poudre a parlé d'un
produit mais qui combine la levure de
boulanger c'est de la boulangerie pour
moi le suc fait partie des ingrédients
de base pour faire du pain et à minutes
que de la levure dans un produit
c'est de la boulangerie c'est pas de la
poterie je vais vous dire une danoise un
croissant une brioche bavure si tous des
potes sucré avec del veut c'est pas de
la partie
le gouvernement canadien nos visages pas
la taxation des pins contenant du sucre
les organismes comme la coalition poids
ne compte pas non plus s'attaquer à ce
dossier
mais avant de justifier une taxe sur un
aliment il faut se demander d'abord
est-ce que l'aliment crée vraiment un
tort sur la santé est ce que les
évidences scientifiques sont là
contrairement aux boissons sucrées ou
ans et l'ont clairement la science que
définie comme étant un élément qui
contribue au diabète de type 2 et
l'obésité et au cancer différentes
maladies cardiovasculaires la boisson
sucrée est nuisible à la santé alors que
pour le point
on ne peut pas d'étude présentement
scientifiques qui viennent justifier
l'imposition d'une taxation spécifique
sur cet aliment le pen blanc il est
peut-être moins nutritifs mais il ya
beaucoup moins cher donc de taxer ce
pain là je trouve que l'on vient toucher
une partie de la population qui ont
peut-être plus de défis à ce niveau là
qui est d'acheter leur pain basse et ça
va devenir quelque chose de plus
compliqué le sillon les taxes l autre
élément qu'il faut garder avant de taxer
un produit c'est aussi de voir si on va
pas créer plus de tort au niveau de la
santé ici on est pour mettre une taxe
sur un produit comme le pain qui est un
aliment de base qui fait partie du
quotidien de plusieurs familles voilà on
vient aussi quand même la valeur du
panier d'épicerie puis on peut avoir des
effets pervers les pins qui contiennent
le plus de sucre présente des toners de
4 à 5 g par portion soit environ une
cuillérée à thé les taxes et frais ils
en sortent de décourager leur
consommation comme certains pays l'ont
fait avec les boissons sucrées la
boisson sucrée elle est un produit non
essentiels qu'on peut très bien se
passer
on est dans un autre catégorie on envoie
un autre signal l'idée de réduire notre
consommation de boissons sucrées au
quotidien avec la taxation s'il part
l'expérience internationale que c'est
efficace à la coalition on souhaite
aussi que le consommateur est accès à
des produits de meilleure qualité
parce qu'on veut c'est aussi que
l'industrie diminue c'est au dessus
peu importe qui on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir 12 g de sucre dans un pain c'est
beaucoup trop
même si on les enrichis en cinq éléments
nutritifs c'est pas ne se retrouve pas
sur la marche haute du classement
les pains tranchés sont considérés comme
des aliments ultra transformer c'est le
cas pour les trois points qu'on a sur la
table
oui parce que même ce pain là qui je
vous dis là contient deux meilleurs
farine mais il contient aussi quelques
agents de conservation puis ces agents
de conservation là et d'autres additifs
besson ajouté pour que l'ami soit plus
agréable pour le consommateur donc c'est
sûr que des produits comme ça avec de
longues listes d'ingrédients baisse ce
sont des produits qui se classe dans les
aliments ultra transformer mais malgré
cela ce n'est pas une raison pour les
taxes est selon nous experts je pensais
pas la bonne cible
et je pense que de temps en temps de
manger un hamburger
pourquoi pas si on a un groupe si le
reste du temps on va plutôt sur dd bonne
farine des bons pains ce qui est
important c'est de prendre le pont herbe
les gens aiment bien les mois le yam les
toucher les pins pour souvenir soupe et
si le sud fait sont aussi quelques mois
le alors morale de l'histoire sa part
c'est un peu comme ça saigne et même un
bon point on peut pas dire le contraire
et que dire de le bar maintenant
[Rires]
[Musique]